ROBERTS: This is a story of
an unlikely friendship that
transformed America forever.
(theme music plays)
♪ Wade in the water ♪
♪ God's gonna
trouble the water ♪
♪ Wade in the water ♪
♪ Wade in the water children ♪
♪ God's gonna
trouble the water ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh ♪ ♪
DOUGLASS: Under his wise
and beneficent rule we saw
ourselves gradually lifted
from the depths of slavery to
the heights of
liberty and manhood...
Though we waited long,
we saw all this and more.
ROBERTS: Abraham Lincoln is
known as "the great emancipator"
but the moniker
wasn't earned overnight.
It would take the tireless work
of the abolitionist movement,
led by Frederick Douglass,
who himself was born enslaved,
to guide Lincoln
towards the cause of freedom.
DOUGLASS: I am alike familiar
with the whip and chain of
slavery and the lash and sting
of public neglect and scorn;
that my back is
marked with the one,
and my soul is
fettered with the other.
ROBERTS: After
years of opposition,
these two giants
would find common ground
and change the
course of history.
Ten years before the
Emancipation Proclamation
was enacted...
LINCOLN: If all earthly
power were given me,
I should not know what to do,
as to the existing institution.
DOUGLASS: O! had I the ability,
and could I reach
the nation's ear,
I would today pour out a fiery
stream of biting ridicule,
blasting reproach, withering
sarcasm and stern rebuke.
For it is not light that
is needed, but fire;
it is not the gentle shower,
but thunder.
(thunder)
MORRIS Jr.: Frederick Douglass
never had a pair of pants or
shoes until he was about
six or seven years old.
He would sleep headfirst in
an old corn sack with his
feet hanging out on
cold winter nights
to try and keep himself warm.
ROBERTS: Teaching the
enslaved to read was illegal.
So young Frederick secretly
traded what little food he had
in exchange for
reading lessons.
MORRIS Jr.: It just shows
how much he understood
how education was going
to be his key to freedom.
ROBERTS: And a key
to freedom it was...
At the age of 20, Douglass
made a daring escape
and went north,
settling in Massachusetts.
There, he soared: From orator...
DOUGLASS: The one cannot
be truly free while
the other is a slave.
ROBERTS: To
newspaper editor...
DOUGLASS: Truth
is of no color.
ROBERTS: And
best-selling author...
DOUGLASS: From that moment,
I understood the pathway
from slavery to freedom.
ROBERTS: He was the
central voice of the
abolitionist movement.
MORRIS Jr.: He had this natural
gift for communication.
He was eloquent.
He was charismatic.
STAUFFER: There wasn't a venue
building large enough to
hold people who
wanted to hear him.
DOUGLASS: Would you have
me argue that man is
entitled to liberty?
That he is the rightful
owner of his own body?
Must I argue the
wrongfulness of slavery?
At a time like this,
scorching irony,
not convincing
argument is needed.
(applause).
ROBERTS: Much of Douglass'
irony was directed towards
Washington, DC and
Abraham Lincoln,
the anti-slavery
president who took office
just as the Civil War
began in 1861.
STAUFFER: Anti-slavery is
very different than
being an abolitionist.
it was very gradual that
most anti-slavery candidates
believed in the
abolition of slavery.
LINCOLN: I do not
suppose that...
ultimate extinction would
occur in less than 100 years
at the least.
STAUFFER: That would have
put the end of slavery in 1958.
And for Frederick Douglass,
that's outrageous.
DOUGLASS: Mr. Lincoln is quite
a genuine representative of
American prejudice...
and far more concerned for
the preservation of slavery.
ROBERTS: Douglass was relentless
in his fight for freedom...
and with the steady drumbeat
of the abolitionist movement
in his ear, Lincoln signed
the Emancipation Proclamation,
freeing enslaved people
in the southern states and
for the first time, making
it legal for all black men
to fight in the Civil War.
These new soldiers injected
the Union army with
much needed manpower.
But still, they faced
discrimination and disparity.
STAUFFER: Douglass
is so outraged that
he makes a trip to D.C.
and decides he wants to
meet with Lincoln himself.
ROBERTS: To his surprise,
Lincoln agreed to
see him immediately.
MORRIS Jr.: He was ushered up
past all of the people that
were waiting to see
Lincoln that day.
And just imagine this
visual of this Black man just
bounding up the steps,
and people are looking
at him like who is that?
STAUFFER: Lincoln
begins the conversation.
And he says,
"Hello, Mr. Douglass,"
essentially,
"It's good finally to meet you.
I've read your writings a lot.
I know you've been
very critical of me."
ROBERTS: Their one-on-one left a
lasting impression on both men,
and Lincoln vowed to improve the
conditions for black soldiers.
DOUGLASS: My whole interview
with the president was
gratifying and did much
to assure me that
slavery would not survive
the war and that the country
would survive both
slavery and war.
ROBERTS: A year later,
it is Lincoln who needs
Douglass's help.
STAUFFER: He feels he is
going to lose reelection.
and essentially
says you know,
"I need you, I think the
war is going badly."
ROBERTS: Lincoln entrusted
Douglass with creating a plan
for aiding the escape of
enslaved people from
rebel territory, so that they
could join the Union cause.
STAUFFER: Douglass writes a
detailed letter to Lincoln
spelling out his vision
of these Special Forces.
DOUGLASS: He did not let me
feel for a moment that there
was any difference in
the color of our skins!
The President is a
most remarkable man.
ROBERTS: With Douglass' support,
Lincoln would go on to
turn the tide of the war
and win re-election.
The following year,
Douglass returned to
Washington once more...
to attend the inauguration.
DOUGLASS: Now in this
multitude of elite of the land,
I felt myself a
man among men.
STAUFFER: It's the first time a
President devotes most of the
speech to African Americans.
LINCOLN: One eighth of
the whole population
were colored slaves...
KENNETH: Frederick Douglass
heard his words and
his language in
Lincoln's address.
LINCOLN: Until every drop
of blood drawn with the lash
shall be paid by another
drawn with the sword...
MORRIS Jr.: The work that he
had done over so many years.
He was now hearing this at a
very important moment in time
in the nation's history.
STAUFFER: Douglass is invited to
the White House for a reception.
He sees Douglass enter
and he yells out...
LINCOLN: Here comes my friend,
Frederick Douglass...
There is no man in the
country whose opinion I value
more than yours.
DOUGLASS: Mr. Lincoln,
that was a sacred effort.
♪ Oh, freedom ♪
♪ Oh, freedom ♪ ♪
MORRIS Jr.: Frederick Douglass
spoke truth to power,
and he never stopped
fighting for his people,
and he understood that
the struggle continued.
He said...
DOUGLASS: Without struggle,
there is no progress...
Power concedes nothing
without a demand.
It never did and
it never will.
♪ Wade in the water ♪
♪ God's gonna
trouble the water ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh ♪
(scatting rhythmically)
Captioned by
Cotter Media Group.